самці проти Росії мало продовжить
автоматично їжі на позицію 28 числа
ницістю ви харчування так а
скошування обидва ослаблення sands ще до
росії можна його наше я хочу москва у
повному апсиді ви клану я розумом і мінських
догляд і що до України тов обмінів не
фока маціон і дося
цьому міністр закордонних довідок я
доповіді то мама за сильного ще для там
ще бабла продав дружину мінську і біля води
дуже і санте шматки дна борошно метати і
німецької економіки кр і таку ці
рішення про продовження санкцій
як заявив голова комітету екхард корду
стукає war теорію обсі виймається до
експорту до Росії може злі зате є
навісимо з статевої але мільярдів євро та
хоча причиною стала наша санкцій їх
пасту за висловлюванням б логвін терасах
у всіх турин поважаючи вин цінного пузата
для не мати до бізнесу головну інтригу 3
травня Італія виступала за продовження
огляду не санкцій прем'єр-міністр
моторин сизо пропилів піднятий випробування
на саміті стп шефа national таймс і ви
клапана роздмухуванням італії києві
наполовину звісткою дивовижному матчі на дати
ська буде ні слова загонів технічний
шляхи до 2 рівень поважають що Берлін
ставити свої економічні інтереси вище
вид колективної дипломатії з fan and
showtime спалах з чорним у сочі
гальмувалися на брюссель за рішення за
благ уват і будемо виступивши даного
потоку шуму постукати й газ із Росії
через італію
це щорічне італійське уряд захопивши
труби ти цінні spooky але на
дипломатичному рівні ohne zu стригти та
на найвищому рівні то наскільки я знаю
рішення вже привід ж але про 1000 санкцій
за лежати вид виконання мінських у ось у
п'ятницю не травневий депутат
європарламенту їжу Москви здавимо
збирається ще раз він прилюдно ти
позиції брюсселя росія музиканти свою
часто нам мінських ось і краще писати url
можна буду говорити і про знаєте про
санкцій